you want to take the easy way out cuz
you thinking life is a journey lasted
journey if you're a [ __ ] Rockefeller
was a hard bastard
Steve Jobs was a ruthless hard bastard
this is what I'm training you to be like
the Four Horsemen of them in Apocalypse
it's never gonna get any better than
this kids this is the eyes they said on
YouTube the eye of the perfect storm
so I'm saying no matter what your age is
it's still time to just go out and do it
need motivation watch a top tune with
believe nation what's that believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in a tough neighborhood
starting his business with only eight
hundred and twenty dollars to then
having over four hundred and fifty
million dollars eight years later he's
dan Pena and here's my take on his top
ten rules success vol 3 also if you want
to know what Dan and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence that like the joint is
in the description below but knowing
does know initially upfront you have to
try if the swing at the plate a kid like
you if you had to keep track of seven
days a week 24 hours a day what you do
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one keep on the going when I was a kid
they said I was [ __ ]
they stood me in the corner with a dunce
cap better people know what a dunce cap
is you know okay and if I turned around
they put me in the closet kept me there
for five six hours
I hated on myself I my pants until my
parents came to pick me up now just
imagine if that had happened to you
but I used it it's not what happens to
you in life it's how you interpret what
happens I made it make me stronger
tougher smarter most people would just
collapse when I played football American
football the coach Roy Jay may he rest
in roasted hell where every years he
says Pina you're so slow you ought to
wear the other team's Jersey do you
understand what that means you're such a
poor athletes put the other Kings jersey
on you no good Russ but I kept on going
hitting that land boom you know I'm
gonna have the tackling exercise one guy
in the middle and everybody just said I
was that guy every day
if that had happened to you I know what
you do some of you would have committed
suicide that it made me stronger
yes I'm 6 foot 1 225 a twisted steel and
Panther piss at age 73
but I endured all this stuff rumor -
don't care what others think the rumor
is that I'm following in the footsteps
of two of my mentors and for those of
you that aren't bright enough to know
that that's Lenin and Stalin and me
there's some truth to that because I
believe in the old Russian way I'm not
interested in your opinions that's the
last thing I need is your opinion
because if your opinion was so good you
wouldn't be here and if you look at my
whole wall of influencers they're both
on there amongst some other people like
the devil and a few others Hitler rule
number three don't be an expert at least
two or three of you have asked me to
privately on one on one or during the
breaks you know I was thinking about
going into such and such but I don't
want to know anything about such and
such how can I do it remember I knew not
enough about the oil and gas business to
fill the top of that pin
I knew less than and by anybody's
imagination or statistics or benchmarks
I was super successful and as I said
earlier a couple days ago now
unfortunately know a lot about the
industry and I haven't made any money in
it in a number of years I want to you
know I haven't because now I look at the
deals
ya know I mean the ratio between gas and
oil and this and that and supply and
demand sonam an expert I've made a
diamond it in 10-15 years because now I
look at it the wrong way I look at it
even though I don't do spreadsheets I
look at it in a spreadsheet manner and I
come up you can always come up with a
reason why not to do something and by
god I've come up with a number of them
over the year in Orland gas rule number
four be tough as nails mr. Carnegie was
a hard
sir Vanderbilt was a hard bastard Henry
Ford the first was a hard bastard
Rockefeller was a hard bastard Steve
Jobs was a ruthless hard bastard as
Apple's CEO Cooke regularly begins
sending emails at 4:30 in the morning on
Sunday he's a hard bastard why are all
these guys they changed the world got
one thing in common take the prisoners
and then we got you a stiff drink and a
good kill most people in this room I'm
ashamed to say and fast forget the stiff
drink just a good my proceeds from
paypal acquisition were 80 180 million
ba-ba-ba-ba then I had a borrow money
for rent these guys myself included are
all in if they believe what they're
doing they put all their money at risk
on which I have several times not in
recent years SpaceX worker reveals a
brutal company motto motto helped him
survive all-nighters working for Elon
Musk notorious workaholic Elon Musk is
so tied to his office that he's been
known to sleep on the floor I slept on
the floor
Ford slept on the poor job slept on the
floor day slept on the floor success
leaves Clues you weenies
I still work 50 60 hours a week and I
haven't had at work in 35 years rule
number five just do it best advice I
ever got from mister Grasso's do it he
didn't say just do it he didn't swear
and the best advice I've ever given
anybody is just do it we take too much
time procrastinating we take too and
because we're afraid of failure in fear
is false expectations appearing real
we're worried about what other people
think we're trying to fit in and I can
go through a whole litany of [ __ ]
not it's not [ __ ] it's not true
litany of stuff why you are where you
are because you just didn't do it you
didn't want to make a mistake you got a
mortgage you got a two ex-wives you've
got a fifteen-year-old daughter who's
pregnant I know you're your dad's got
Alzheimer's your mother's got emphysema
spitting up blood I can go on and on and
on and on but the bottom line is if you
had 15 years ago you had just done it 10
years ago you just done it five years
ago if you just done it six months ago
if you just done it you probably
wouldn't be in the position you're in
now so I'm saying no matter what your
age is it's still time to just go out
and do it just go on do it
rule number six be a warrior this is
what I'm training you to be like the
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
warriors not whiners
not warriors do you think Donald Trump
is a whiner do you think he worries and
gives up what you think of them do you
think Elon Musk gives up what you think
of them you think the late Steve Jobs
gives it gave up what you thought of
them do you think Bill Gates gives up
and I go on and on and on the only one
that gives us what you and you and you
and you and the morons on YouTube rule
number seven leave your comfort zone
most of you have not attained material
wealth
because you've stayed in your comfort
zone every family has a aunt an uncle a
grandfather then went out lost the
family fortune right uncle hairy crazy
hairy you lost twenty thousand fifty
thousand a million whatever the number
is
well that resonates in you in your brain
your little pea brain and then you hear
another one your roommate in college
he's got an uncle Harry so pretty soon
the only input that you have is people
losing their family fortune that affects
you ie you then live within your comfort
zone
ie you don't take risks a tortoise a
turtle can only move forward when it
sticks its head and its feet out and
when it sticks its head and its feet out
it's most vulnerable right biggest risk
most of you have lived a bubble-wrap
life most of you have been risk-averse
risk-averse to the extent there are
people beyond my comprehension
that get all the way through high school
would never been screamed at never been
slapped never been in a fight never been
reprimanded by their parents and then
look at him
snowflakes snowflakes meaning they melt
under pressure and when I say that world
is through look at you the reason why
the aliens haven't come down and take it
why why are they gonna learn anything no
rule number eight love what you do it is
simple can everybody in this room do it
no because everybody in this room is not
willing to make the sacrifices I don't
know how to do it four hour work week
which came up a little earlier I don't
know and I know Ferriss and if you
believe the 4-hour workweek I've had a
bridge to sell you in New York I mean
one of the comments from the seminar
that just ended from the 1820 kids all
of which were about half my age we had a
couple of old gits in their 40s but most
of them were less than 30 they commented
at breakfast the last day which was
Saturday or Sunday they said how can he
still be so fired up running on two
hundred percent of all its cylinders
when he's been on his feet 15 hours a
day for six seven eight days and we've
been sitting on our arses and we're
tired and he's not you know why because
I and if you don't find something that
you love what you do don't bother
because if you don't have a passion for
what you do and your love it gets old I
say this stretching a little it's like a
significant other that you've been
around too much you know what I mean
everybody in this room can relate to
that I think ok well if you're not
passionate about what you do in life it
gets old and then it becomes work and as
soon as it becomes work you're finished
the reason why I'm fired up at the end
of a six seven day week of 15 18 hours a
day is because I'm passionate about
pulling you sorry asses across the goal
line because that's my goal in life now
to pull as many of the sorry individuals
on the planet across the goal line as I
can before they put dirt on me
rule number nine turn your life into a
process I want to take the easy way out
because you think in life it's a journey
that is horseshit life's a journey if
you're a [ __ ]
and you're [ __ ] that's why you're
not so that's what you've done with the
life up here too far it's been a journey
and how good is the journey you tell me
wouldn't you rather when the first time
you went out with somebody that you
thought you're in love with thought is
the operative word
once you have lied to have a template oh
let's follow this process instead of
because that is a journey and all the
mistakes you made and raising this
little shed for kids you got instead of
having this book wife doesn't have to be
a journey it's a journey for morons do
you think life is a journey for the
Trump kids that's a process the same
process his daddy raised him by same for
me life ain't a journey with fear my kid
it's a goddamn process till you tell me
if your results orientate it at all
who's better off the journey or the
process and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
seize the opportunity right now on
November 8th I announced that when mr.
Trump whether you
love them or hate them this was the
beginning of the greatest transformation
of wealth the world has ever seen since
World War two now what are you what are
you gonna tell your kids and your
grandkids 25 years from now when they
say gee daddy gee grandpa what were you
doing other than having your thumb up
your big ass during the greatest
transformation of wealth and the history
of the world what were you doing oh
nothing
that's what most of you will tell them
your grandchildren and your children
it's never going to get any better than
this kids this is the eyes I said on
YouTube the eye of the perfect storm
this is it I never thought I'd live to
see it again
this is going to make the 80s look like
a nursery rhyme which I praise Allah
praise Buddha praise God I participated
and slashing and raping everybody in the
80s legally this is going to make that
look like a nursery rhyme and what are
you going to tell your kids oh I had a
spreadsheet I had to think about how to
read another book on M&A you morons
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Dan on how to keep an open mind that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing question signed a
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what
opportunity in front of you do you need
to seize today number two how will you
leave your comfort zone to seize it and
number three when others criticize you
what will you do think and say to
yourself
if you are not experiencing anxiety if
your problems are not replaced as soon
as you solve one with a bigger one
that's geometrically bigger then you're
not growing I hate to hear people tell
me my business is running smoothly
everything's great
well then he might as well or she might
as well blow their brains out because it
sure as hell aren't growing what my deal
is all about is growing geometrically
quantumly
and just remember that and keep an open
mind because I have been there and done
that there's no question about that yeah
yeah another thing and I said this
yesterday just because you haven't done
it just because you've never been around
somebody that hasn't done that hasn't
done it and just because you've never
heard of it doesn't mean it doesn't
exist because absence of evidence is not
evidence of their absence I'm going to
say some things that are real foreign to
you some things that you've been taught
by your parents your grandparents in
school and basically all that is crap
now I'm not talking about moral issues
and things like that a religion I don't
get into that I was raised a Roman
Catholic if that desi and I'm still a
Roman Catholic and my wife's a convert
Catholic if that gives you any idea
about where I stand on religion but I'll
be glad to debate anything at during the
break so just keep an open mind the high
performance people that I will continue
to allude to all day long live in a
different world than you they came from
the same world as you did but they live
in a different world they think
differently
if you want more Dane pina check out
this first top ten rules video that we
made I think you'll enjoy it the link is
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there
self-esteem is the key to high
performance it's not work if you love
what you're doing and most of you don't
believe passionately in what you're
doing